des images un peu plus tôt regarder les
deux vrais aventuriers modernes
l'expédition s'appelle les chemins de
l'or bleu et c'est pas des blagues on a
deux membres de l'expédition avec nous
mais on va d'abord je vais vous dire
bonjour martin train bonjour mme sirois
bonjour années que charles yann bonjour
à vous c'est exceptionnel ce que vous
avez fait 7000 km en canot vous êtes
parti cent soixante quinze jours deux
canaux du vrai canola sauvage on va
regarder la carte en sang pour donner
une idée aux gens qui nous écoutent
cette partie de hockey à quel moment
cette partie des cas le 25 avril 2015
nous sommes partis dans mon cas il nous
avons terminé l'expédition à inuvik dans
les territoires du nord-ouest
le 16 octobre dernier d'incroyables 175
jours sept mille kilos mais j'ai fait
les grands lacs les traversées les
grands lacs
vous avez fait toutes les rivières qui
communiquer entre elles des portages
sûtra faut être fou pour avoir mis sur
pied cette expédition a effectivement
faut être un peu fou comme vous l'avez
mentionné cent soixante quinze jours
d'avancé sur 7000 km 117 portage c'est
un rêve que je caressais depuis les huit
dernières années ça a été difficile pour
moi de trouver des gens aussi assez fou
pour se joindre à mon équipe et à force
de travailler fort on a réussi à monter
une équipe de rêve et c'était un réel
succès que les chemins de leurs bleus
ont réussi à faire cette année annick
championne pourquoi j'étais embarqué
là-dedans ben pour ma part ça fait ou de
25 ans que c'est un rêve de traverser
canada qu'à nous donc ce projet est
passé plus d'une fois sous mon nez et la
deuxième fois
là j'ai décidé que c'était le temps où
jamais d'embarquer dans le projet je
regrette pas du tout du tout du tout ça
a été vraiment un accomplissement très
important dans ma vie en fait je
comprends pour donner qu'est-ce qui est
le plus difficile c'est quoi le grand
défi quand on décide de faire sa belle
aux grands défis selon moi c'est d'être
isolé pendant aussi longtemps d'être
aussi loin de ses proches de sa famille
de son amoureux et amoureuses d'avoir
peu de moyens de communication justement
pour donner signe de vie
tous les dangers pour ceux qui
connaissent le canot camping il ya les
ours
il ya le risque de dessaler vous avez
parlé tantôt du lac supérieur hulu est
environ à 2 3 degrés celsius
c'est une mer intérieure où les vagues
et les vents peuvent se lever rapidement
très dangereux donc long de danger tout
au long du parcours et je dirais que
pour moi vraiment c'était c'était des
moments plutôt difficile sur le lac
supérieur le justement parce que le
risque était omniprésent la société
géographique royale du canada vous a
donné dix mille dollars parce que elle
l'a jugé que c'était l'expédition
canadienne de l'année donc on ne fait
pas ça souvent ce genre d'affaires ne le
sait pas à la portée de tous
non faut quand même avoir une certaine
expérience en la matière
se lance pas dans ce peu importe qu'il
faut savoir un peu qu est ce qui s'en
vient les difficultés physiques que ça
engendre quand même faut faut savoir
qu'on dort pas dans un lycée une tente
la température il ya évidemment les
animaux elle entend aussi la nourriture
qui pensent qu'on mange tous les jours
ce sera pas ainsi que tous les soirs
mais des trucs les hydrater utilisé
c'est qu'il faut faut savoir un peu
d'accord s'embarque effective est ce
qu'il ya des moments dans des rapides
parce que bien sûr javier des cartes
mais il ya des rapides que vous ne
connaissiez pas bien sûr à traverser le
canada ce que j'ai dit oh là là ça
marche plus mais je voudrais qu'on a
frôlé la catastrophe à environ cinq
jours de la fin on était fatigués on a
fait une erreur de débutant de ne pas
aller voir les rats pire de sa grosse à
la trajectoire à suivre et une fois leur
envie d'entamer on a vu la grosseur des
vagues montée devant nous et je vous
dirais que j'ai vraiment craint de ne
pas parce que la température était très
froide ans ou 0 il y avait de la neige
et de la glace au sol l'eau était
presque sur le point de congélation et
le canot s'est rempli d'eau s'est rempli
d'eau parce que notre toile de pontage
en fait aux cdo déchiré et on avait
vraiment sous-estimé la grosseur du
rapide donc effectivement erreurs à ne
pas faire mais je voudrais que sans
doute n'y avait pas beaucoup de rats
pire à descendre dans notre expédition
la majorité des rapides on les a
remontés soit à bras corus est trop
facile de s'imposer
il ya finalement l'objectif ultime parce
que c'est pas pour une émission de
télévision c'est pas pour vous faire de
l'argent vous avez quelques commandite
je le disais la société canadienne 10000
dollars mais vous n'êtes pas riche avec
celle là c'est le dépassement
oui effectivement c'est de réussir à
faire quelque chose qui sort un peu de
l'ordinaire c'est pas nécessairement une
petite expédition qui qu'on met sur pied
en trois jours dont il est déjà le
travail préalable à ce qui s'est étendue
sur à peu près de deux ans ensuite de
soin de faire c'est de se rendre au bout
et fallu
découpez le trajet en certaines sections
pour qu'on puisse avancer se rendre à
terme avant la glace en fait l'enjeu
principal était de se rendre à inuvik
avant que ça soit julie en fait donc ça
a été un petit peu un marathon par bout
et ça ça doit vraiment forcer à a dit
rené de manière assidue du camp si je
peux ajouter enfin sur ouais c'était
aussi de démontrer qu'on n'a pas besoin
d'être un grand homme pour réaliser de
grandes choses
quand on a un rêve et qu'on s'y
accrochent et qu'on le réalise on se
sent vivant et en ce qui me concerne ça
a été les 6 plus beau mois de ma vie
gardez image là c'est extraordinaire les
aurores boréales gt ou là on était sur
la rivière aux esclaves dans les
territoires-du-nord-ouest pouvoir
vraiment et les aurores boréales que
vous voyez à l'écran en ce moment on est
quelques-uns à avoir dormi à la belle
étoile
cette nuit là justement pour pouvoir les
apprécier martine rahier que familial de
jeu félicitations bravo on tenait à
souligner vous êtes arrivé aujourd'hui
de cet extraordinaire périple à travers
le pays
en canoë il n'ya pas de triche il en
canot en portage félicitations mercy
emmène sur maman